we were in new york we were at
serendipity i took both the girls there
just kind of like a fun we used to
always go there when we yeah when they
were little
and we're having a great time and all of
a sudden paris said
i don't know if i want to get married
that's normal
everyone gets like that right
um i guess
did you
not this time
[Laughter]
you know what else i think she's such a
little girl and an adult body maybe it's
just scary for her the thought of
actually getting married and i know
being like a real grown-up
i don't mean you're right or even having
to think of the list and the people and
then it's pressure and she's such a busy
person anyway with so much going on
sometimes it's just all too much
it's all too much
because you know there's also so much
attention and focus on her and the
wedding
imagine if you have that pressure as
opposed to somebody who's
not in the public eye if they change
their mind it's like okay you don't send
them she said i feel like a failure like
i'm disappointing like all the people
that are
what would mom have said
if one of us said this
that we were scared to get married
and already and she probably would have
said well do you really better think
twice
mm-hmm
well is she gonna know enough before we
all go spending all this money i if
she's fine now she's fine now
but i got so down
so i'm meeting later with a therapist
okay so you're gonna have a therapist
right okay also i wanted to talk about
the documentary
and discuss some of those issues
about the stuff that she went through or
how it affected you or both both
i came from a home where
nobody went to a therapist so the other
kathy maybe years ago
would have swept it under the carpet and
maybe thought it would go away
if you don't discuss it
i think it's a good idea though to talk
to somebody
naturally smart actually
i mean we never went to therapists or
anything like that no
[Music]
but we did do
was have family meetings
[Music]
right
how many people will be at the wedding
250.
that's a tight list for someone who
knows that many people right hello
hi sweetie kim i was thinking wait where
did you used to get the french tips from
the garbage
well we already started eating so
and this is nice and light
like yeah i know i'm like i'm trying to
be healthy and i'm eating pasta and i
keep putting three noodles at a time
thinking that's gonna make a difference
kathy i love the little bobbles on your
phone they're so cute
well they're very on trend my girls have
that too
so cute right
hi honey how are you
good how are you hi honey hi
um we're just going over some things
right now i wanted to know
hello
don't talk what i'm talking i'm getting
tired i want to know
maybe we use
the driveway
as
the place where everybody watches you
walk up the driveway
that's steep that's not a bet she
doesn't care and long
on what the wedding on the driveway i'm
just thinking going up the driveway that
could be your aisle
and then everybody could be seated
around that beautiful
it's a mile long i think paris isn't
yeah
they like to see the father you know and
the daughter walk down right and then
they get to stop and have a moment
outside the house before walking down to
see all the people it'd be so nice and
it's gonna be one of those i can't
believe i'm doing this i can't make
people down there you're gonna get so
excited
i could cry just thinking about it oh my
god where do you envision yourself
walking down
actually no not the driveway mom because
the whole point of it is seeing the
gorgeous house in the background
remember where i landed the helicopter
from simple life yes there
and paris you remember uh where i took
my wedding photos and you were my
bridesmaid
that whole backdrop was the back of
brook lawn
oh yeah maybe you could come in like
from the second floor where papa and
nana's balcony like tinkerbell like
flying down we can we can hoist you down
what do you think no it should be a
production
i like that it's a harness under your i
think they should fly out
i think they both should play out i
think they should be you should have on
a cape i think they should pony ride in
and the horse and fly out no he's gonna
imagine in the middle of the day
everybody almost something
you're married
yeah you i like that she doesn't want to
miss the party though so she can't fly
out in the middle and then you go she
flies in
i don't know what you would be brought
down like tinkerbell and there'd be
lights
would you fly around the whole property
with a spotlight am i going to fly
around the location
coordinators handle this
[Music]
you